miss Colombia will sit down with Steve  Harvey for an on-camera interview for  the first time since the miss universe  pageant et can exclusively revealed that  Ariana Gutierrez and Steve Harvey will  come face-to-face on his show The Steve  Harvey Show in an interview expected to  air the week of January 18th this will  mark the first time the two have met  publicly since the notorious miss  universe pageant mishap I have to  apologize this universe later told ET  she hopes the mix-up will have a silver  lining for the future for Adriana I hope  that she should very soon realizes that  she has a lot of opportunities she's  beautiful she's talented and this will  open so many doors for her